recording now only thirty two percent of
americans say that they are proud of the
election that saw Donald Trump selected
as the next president of the United
States now you might say well that's
because things are so polarized and
there's always only about a third of
Americans who are proud of the election
results well that's not true because in
2008 sixty-seven percent of Americans
were proud that President Obama had been
elected president of the United States
and this really goes to what I've been
talking about about the embarrassment on
the world stage that the election of
Donald Trump is already and is going to
be Gallup had a very interesting poll
that they've been doing for a while
reacting to Donald Trump's election and
I'll put up some of the highlights for
you to look at and tell you about them
in twenty sixteen eighty percent of
Trump supporters are excited about the
results in two thousand eight fifty nine
percent of all respondents were excited
and that represents a pretty significant
difference where the excitement right
now is very heavily concentrated among
Donald Trump supporters only now in
terms of fear seventy-six percent of
Clinton supporters say they are afraid
of the election results in two thousand
eight twenty-seven percent of all
respondents were afraid and that sort of
makes sense because the fear of an Obama
presidency was really more concentrated
among the fringe it was very much based
on President Obama's identity whereas
the fear of the trump presidency is much
more related to policy and what it is
that Trump is actually promised to do
during the campaign and as I mentioned
the most interesting maybe piece of this
survey is that thirty two percent of all
respondents say that they are proud of
the election of Donald Trump uh less
than half of the number sixty-seven
percent that in 2008 said they were
proud of the election of President
Barack Obama the proud one is really
very telling and the math checks out
because think about it twenty-seven
percent
of eligible voters voted for Donald
Trump there presumably mostly proud I
would guess I mean they did vote for the
guy plus some of the people that didn't
vote at all the numbers would probably
be very similar if Hillary Clinton had
won the election the type of of
difference in in in the proud and fear
thing that I'm thinking about is what
are we proud of and what would we be
afraid of Hillary Clinton Pat is a
status quo ludicrous centrist Democrat
beholdin to the oleg arts and there
would be some fear about that but Donald
Trump is a narcissistic sociopath who's
interested in being president for the
idea of it and the power that it brings
but not actually to do the job not all
fear is created equal although mites
might my thought is if Hillary Clinton
had one and you had asked people who's
proud who's afraid the numbers may not
necessarily have been drastically
different I think the stark difference
often has to do with the fact that we
elected the first black president in
2008 yeah I'm and we may have seen
numbers similar to that because we had
the first election of a woman president
but given her unfavorables they probably
wouldn't have been so high as it was for
Obama Donald Trump does have to appear
in court for fraud we will talk about
the details of what he's trying to do
with with regard to that a little bit
later on in the show you have an
individual here who has made a lot of
money screwing crimes contractors and
investors to the point where at one
point major banks would not loan him
money the campaign has been in contact
with the Russian government while that
same government hacked Democratic email
servers he has very few policy positions
of his own the ones he does have if God
forbid they actually come to fruition
would likely be disastrous economically
so I think that the the word fear we
talk about fear and fear mongering a lot
but the fears that existed among a
Clinton uh uh uh in in relation to a
potential Clinton presidency are very
different than the fears that we are
talking about with a Donald Trump
presidency the polls certainly reflect
that this was
uh an election that saw an unusual
electorate varied motivations for why
people were voting either for or against
and I am genuinely curious and this is
not a rhetorical question this is not me
implying anything I'm genuinely curious
to see as the Donald Trump presidency
stars and continues what kind of
approval ratings is Donald Trump going
to have